[Music]
okay we just got done seeing how to tree
and dragon who was it forbidden world
was hidden hidden world
right it's kind of like a fantasy
adventure for the whole family one of
the animated ones and I have to say the
animation is really good there were a
couple shots there where it was hard to
tell there was animation like when they
flew down the waterfall you know it
ended a hidden earth when they went down
in there and the subterranean world it
looked pretty good story was pretty
tight yeah I think that I think the
movie you know did a good job of being
what it was trying to do there were some
time there whatever there were moments
where it almost gave you too much work
well too long
say like on dragons in love and [ __ ] and
yeah you know I mean it was just
sometimes the cutesy just went over the
[ __ ] top but I think that's calm
maybe what the audience wants when they
see these movies I mean you know we're
not really the attend intended audience
yeah and it's kind of like centers very
much around the Dragons as well as the
human character yeah but because I
remember seeing the person a long time
ago but I didn't remember him losing his
leg yes so maybe that happened in the
second one I feel like that was a long
time ago but yeah I had to say like I
really really liked it like I liked a
lot of them I mean the animation was
like spectacular yeah especially like
when they actually find the hidden world
and but I think the best thing about it
like other than like I said it's a good
story it was it was a pretty tight story
I think the best thing about it is like
the supporting characters I remembered
about the original into like just the
kind of goofy other people in the
village that are like kind of funny and
[ __ ] like that the only thing I could
knock it for in terms of visual stuff is
I thought the humans actually didn't
quite look realistic enough I think they
should have looked a little bit but that
was just my opinion yeah I guess some of
the dragons and some of the like that
the backgrounds it look real some of it
it did yeah
you know it would and it but it kind of
came and went
sometimes it looked a cartoonist
sometimes they look more real it didn't
really seem to be kind of consistent but
I still enjoy it was enjoyable yeah yeah
I really liked and I liked all the you
know it's about biking so it's kind of
all like that yeah it's in a Norse motif
yeah it's like all really cool okay no
it's like really nice shots by
candlelight yeah yeah actually it's like
I said I don't remember if it was the
third one but I remember like in the
first one - oh that was a long time ago
that I saw yeah yeah you know I think it
did a good job you know what it was
trying to do yeah yeah it's successful
it's not what I go out and see this
summer I'll heart pay for it nah not
really but you know it's a family movie
you know and for people that like the
books and stuff so yeah yeah yeah
you
okay just getting out of seeing one it's
called fighting with my family it's
about the wrestler page girl from
England who joins the but she came from
a wrestling family and she comes down
here and joins the WWE yeah it was a
good movie yeah it's written and
directed by Stephen Merchant who you
don't think about British comedy he did
it the office extras an Idiot Abroad
yeah he was one of the writers on Hot
Fuzz so if you're super into that kind
of stuff
this will be right up your alley it's it
like I said it's a true story and I like
it the at the end they showed like
almost kind of like a documentary about
the real family and like they what they
look like and stuff like that but this
is like this was just like a really it
was a like a really fun like funny yes a
really charming yeah but it wasn't zany
it wasn't a comedy through the whole
thing you know some bad [ __ ] happen to
just told you know David any just told
the story what happened you know and one
of things that was cool is that the that
the the girl I don't know what's name
the actors have played page in this we
can't remember a name but it's funny cuz
like they show her coming to Orlando
where she's doing the tryouts and
running around downtown it's just up the
street here I know I know
yeah yeah so she's running around our
stomping grounds you know weather
filling them come the show it was a good
movie yeah I recommend it like I said
it's it's funny but it's not I don't
even know if I'd necessarily call it a
comedy
it has comedic mix comedy drama yeah
about big frost isn't it like playing
her dad and I love him like yeah and
he's like a real highlight of this but
like I said it's you know it's got funny
moments but there's also kind of some
diner moments as well because there's
you know there was a whole kind of thing
where you know and they showed him the
trailers to that her her and the brother
both tried out and her brother didn't
make it yeah and you know there was all
this conflict because of that so
yeah provides like kind of a lot of
heart for the movie as well but I just
you know I just thought this was just
like a really really it was a really
sweet movie and a little funny yeah and
it was what was kind of cool is that the
the coach explains to the movie why he
didn't pick the brother yeah and you
find out why it was probably for in the
but brother's best interests that he
didn't get picked yeah it's mine what
would even though it was like really
hard right yeah I felt bad for him you
know but right cuz he had been his like
you know like I said she and this has a
true story her whole family they ran
like a wrestling gym like in Norwich
England had taught like other kids to
wrestle and you know their sister our
brother like it wrestled each other like
growing up and you know money and
whatnot so you know that the big
conflict of like her getting picked on
him not yeah and then him having to like
deal with why he didn't get picked to do
why she did and what she was gonna
famous and he wasn't and all this other
kind of stuff but so I thought that was
like a really nice aspect at the main
meetings but yeah I would definitely
recommend it like I said Stephen
Merchant I liked everything he did so I
was expecting to like this woman I
really did like it good movie yeah
okay we just got out of once
called Gretta and it was a horror
thriller it was about this girl named
Frances who's living in New York she's a
waitress and she picks up this stalker
this is a woman I think she's probably
in her 60s you know cute as a bug a
little bitty woman and she can't get rid
of her she gets worse and worse the sick
it was good man I'm not gonna spoil it
it was the acting was good had a lot of
good score was good good songs in it
[ __ ] weird weird but in a good way it
was a [ __ ] weird movie just I can't
spoil it I mean if you've seen the
trailers because you know they should
the trailer a lot for other movies you
know you'll be familiar with the premise
yeah the stalkers actually played by
Isabella there yeah whoo I'm like a big
fan of hers yeah she's gotta be in her
60s huh I think she is yeah yeah cute
though yeah 60 you know she cute little
one yeah and I so I was a big fan of her
so I was actually very excited to see
this and I really like Chloe grace
Moretz as well who plays Francis and I
kind of love this cuz like I said this
is like a creepy like stalker thriller
and the thing about casting Isabella
Paris the stalker is was really kind of
genius because you would never suspect a
woman that looked like that yeah at that
age she's all small and she's French and
she's all proper and everything like
that you would never expect that first
you can be like oh yeah so I think so it
so it had that kind of added thing where
you know
poor Francis is trying to go about her
life and she has this like woman going
after her and like no one really
believes her no one like takes it
seriously because you know it's not like
a big hulking dude or anything like that
it's just this little spike equipment
yeah you know what I mean Francis was
played by that actress to play a girl
from yes yeah but not everybody knows
who that is one played Hit Girl and what
was the name of the superhero movie
kick-ass yeah she's been in a bunch of
others she was in she was in the remake
of let the bright woman as well the
American remake yeah [ __ ] I think she
was in the Carrie remake - yeah thinking
about it but yeah I really like this
movie like I said the look of it was
really cool like you said the score was
actually really good and they used like
a lot of kind of creepy old music a lot
of classical music and I thought it was
really good and some of the plot twists
were we're pretty cool like I said it it
sort of goes along like kind of you know
a stalker thriller type of plot but then
there's like kind of all this other
weird yeah that happens and a couple it
was gory or the night just a couple of
times but I was kind of like oh yeah
move it the movie was better than I
thought it was gonna be yeah it's a very
high-quality well-written low-budget
movie shot well acting was good just you
know yeah it was super fun a good horror
movie if we're coming out of there near
some guy while I was on Metro for movie
like thinking about seduced [ __ ] a
horror-movie married a little over here
his fight because it was a mascara
didn't just crowds man these crowds man
I'm glad I'm glad we mostly come see
this [ __ ] yeah there's a next to me he
must weigh 500 pounds he could barely
breathe if you're so heavy you can't
breathe it's time to lose of a [ __ ]
it was a very crowded theater but they
were generally pretty good like I was
afraid like
home theaters man or something be sad
for I mean [ __ ] I'm on a list why can't
they just stream a list to right to our
house gonna have to come here you know I
mean just streaming [ __ ] right to you
like yes yeah why don't want to leave
the house just sit there [ __ ] drink a
cuckoo car yeah watch Greece you got a
green feature man yeah yeah shut this
[ __ ] down
[Music]